I thought it was just PowerPoint presentations from college or from my high school time.
They were really professional PowerPoint presentations...
...used by McKinsey's consultants, with their clients.
You have this information and you have to be able to think,
"How do I put this in a way that it's visually appealing for the people?"
"How do I make sure that the message is being understood right?"
We work with a lot of information, the entire day...
...and we need to keep our standards really high.
So, we need to pay attention to the details all the time.
We have teams in Poland, in India and in Costa Rica.
Our team is no longer in the same table.
We are across continents.
We do receive information from consultants that, for example,...
..."Oh, this presentation will be shown for an audience of 400 people."
We realize how impactful our job can be.
I think that being able to contribute to someone else in their daily basis...
...and maybe take off a little bit of that load that they already have,...
...it's pretty much like the reason that we continue to do this and continue to improve.